you
[Music]
the third of this trilogy
ix in these nine films
Danny Leibovitz come and document the
work that's being done in just it's it's
a gift
Annie has been a part of this saga for
almost 40 years
she's sharing in the culmination of this
with all of us
it's an incredible honor to have her
step in and capture this moment it feels
like a proper journey we were in the
desert for the first one and our hairs
from the last one
I feel very nostalgic at many many
points that this is all
everyone says you can't get experiences
like this very often
it has been this incredible journey I'm
gonna miss it so much me Daisy and Oscar
it's like a moment in all of our lives
really
this is truly it is a present honor
hi everyone its charlie they released a
new Star Wars Episode nine preview I'll
talk about that but the even bigger news
you probably saw last night everyone was
freaking out was that it was confirmed
that they're doing a Star Wars Knights
of the Old Republic movie trilogy that's
actually separate from the other two
trilogies that you've heard are coming
after the Skywalker saga is over sol
explained all this new Star Wars footage
and all the Knights of the Old Republic
stuff if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Star
Wars videos I will be doing episode
videos for Star Wars the Mandalorian
when it premieres this November but
we're not gonna get another trailer for
that probably til the summer maybe Comic
Con or something a little bit later than
that so don't worry there's gonna be a
ton of new Star Wars stuff dropping at
the end of the year mostly because the
Star Wars the Mandalorian in Star Wars
Episode nine but they'll also be
slipping in a lot of news about this
other stuff that's coming down the road
particularly Knights of the Old Republic
so just to start with the new footage
you probably like wait a minute the
Knights of Ren we're getting all this
crazy new stuff what's going on with
Emperor Palpatine what are they gonna do
with the Jedi Order after this is Luke
going to be a force ghost are we gonna
get Luke Skywalker flashbacks
will we get Palpatine flashbacks a bunch
of people went to visit the set of Star
Wars Episode nine when they were filming
a lot of this stuff so they got all
these details first big one is that
we're gonna learn a lot about the origin
of the first-order whereas like an
episode 7 we picked up with them you
don't really know exactly how the galaxy
got to this state what happened to the
Empire what happened to the New Republic
how did things deteriorate so much why
did Leia have to spit off and create the
resistance why did she leave the New
Republic there are some novels that
explain a little bit of this but
typically what the movies do is that
they cover material that are not covered
in the novels the last big Imperial
battle before the official end of the
Empire was the battle of jakku
there was this emperor palpatine super
weapon that the empire was trying to get
their hands on in a last-ditch attempt
to get rid of the rebellion before it
completely rose up they lost that battle
there was a coup within the remaining
Imperial ranks that were still a number
of Star Destroyers left so the person
that won that battle within the Empire
took control of the remains and jumped
into hyperspace to the Unknown Regions
where they lay dormant and turned into
what would eventually become the first
order with the help of Supreme Leader
Snoke
it's also implied that we'll learn a lot
about snoke's history during this movie
too because there were so many teasers
that were jumping back in history to
explain a lot of things that were not
explained during episode 7 like what's
going on here all this brand-new stuff
one of the other major things that
they're talking about for episode 9 is
if the movie's going to deepen the
forced connection between kylo Ren and
Rey you know those forced Skype sessions
that you saw during last Jedi supposedly
it goes way way deeper than we saw in
that movie in their connection on a
metaphorical and a physical level is
much bigger than we've thought before
but they also said that the movie is
going to be the climax of a millennia
long war between the Jedi Order and the
Sith so I'm sure that has something to
do with what Emperor Palpatine is doing
during the movie or at least his force
spirit that's probably trying to come
back there's a lot of rumors about
Palpatine's force spirit trying to
inhabit the body of someone in present
day to sort of resurrect himself so to
speak but we've seen that plot and a lot
of the other comics if you ever read the
dark empire comics Emperor Palpatine has
a lot of clones during that that his
four spirit can then jump into
essentially making him immortal but
whatever they're doing with him trying
to come back during Episode nine it's
not gonna be a bunch of clones sitting
around but obviously you see the
wreckage of the second Death Star so
clearly there's gonna be a lot of
Palpatine stuff going on but a lot of
you will be really happy to know as you
saw during this footage that we're gonna
see a lot from the Knights of Ren
they're supposedly big characters during
the movie like this one here has a
blaster for an arm
c-3po has a much bigger role in the
movie remember Darth Vader made him when
he was Anakin Skywalker so he's sort of
like the robot son of Darth Vader I've
already talked a lot about the Carrie
Fisher scenes most of you probably know
that they're basically using deleted
scenes from her in Episode seven in new
context so it'll be old footage of
Carrie Fisher made to look new and it'll
probably be relatively seamless so you
won't be able to tell the difference we
found out the Carey Russell's character
his name is Zoe bliss she's a rogue with
this badass looking outfit we meet her
in the thieves quarter on a planet
called qiji me which isn't an ice planet
but there's a lot of snow so it's
probably this place here that we see
during the last big trailer the name of
the desert planet that we saw the last
trailer is called husana the aliens that
live there these people are called the
aqui aqui they shot these scenes in the
exact same place with a shot Lawrence of
Arabia if you're big filmmaking geek
then you probably recognize this tour
the last big teaser we finally found out
who Richard II grant his plane during
the movie they've been teasing him for a
long time
his name is Allegiant general pride he
is not general Hux his father but as you
can see he's very important person
within the structure of the first order
Richard II grant is a fantastic actor
he's amazing at playing bad guys so I'm
just really excited to see what he's
gonna be doing the other new character
is John uh we don't know exactly what
she's doing but they did say that these
animals at the writing like horses are
called or backs a lot of people are
wondering if she's gonna wind up being
Lando's daughter Billy Dee Williams says
some funny stuff during the celebration
panel about that but I don't think he
was trying to confirm or deny anything
Luke Skywalker's obviously coming back
they didn't say that it could be forced
ghosts Luke but we could also get Luke
Skywalker flashbacks which actually
seems more interesting to me because
there's this whole history of Luke
Skywalker that we just brushed over
during last Jedi like wait a minute what
was he doing this whole time since kylo
Ren took off and destroyed his temple
most of the voiceover that we got during
the actual trailer makes it sound more
like force ghosts so that's what I'm
expecting most of Luke Skywalker seems
to be but it just implies because we're
gonna be learning about the origin the
first order in all this Palpatine stuff
they'll have to explain what happened
after the Battle of Endor
they'll have to be at least a couple
flashbacks the other big thing too is
that they're going back and forth about
what the actual meaning of the title is
the rise of Skywalker so most people
think Skywalker they think about a
person oh you know maybe this means Ben
solo is going to be doing something
during the movie because technically
he's the last of the Skywalker bloodline
through Leia but now people behind the
movie are also suggesting that Skywalker
is going to be the term for a new type
of force user the New Jedi Order that
rises up out of the ashes of the old
Jedi Order if you haven't read any of
the newer Star Wars books there's a new
thron saga that Timothy Zahn has been
writing and within it there's a force
ability that's called quote-unquote sky
walking which is basically using the
force to navigate through hyperspace
they did say that rey and kylo ren would
manifest brand new force abilities that
we've never seen before in this movie
they've had a little bit of time to
Train Reyes had a little bit of time to
read through some of the force journals
but not through everything so there will
be some cool new force powers but if
Skye walking is one of them
Walker is the name of a new type of Jedi
order that she creates after the events
of this movie we don't completely know
so it's still wide open to speculation
but I wouldn't be surprised if they
pulled some twist like that so that from
a branding and from a merchandising
standpoint they can still use the
Skywalker name even if kylo Ren winds up
dying in the Skywalker bloodline dies
out Skywalker's will still be a very big
thing in the Star Wars canon which makes
sense they would do something like that
like Skywalker name will be so important
to Star Wars even in 50 years it'll
still be a really big thing when they're
on to other really big characters and
plots so don't be surprised that they
pull some crazy twist like that like
what are we gonna call this special new
order what about Skywalker's moving into
Knights of the Old Republic territory I
know you're all wondering what's going
on with Knights of the Old Republic when
are we gonna see that movie we have so
reminder that there's gonna be hiatus in
the next Star Wars movie after episode 9
won't come till the end of 2020 - but
it'll basically be December Star Wars
movies from here on out so instead of
doing a Star Wars movie every single
year they're going back to a movie every
other year they're gonna use the Disney
Plus series like the Mandalorian TV
series in the potential obi-wan TV
series to fill the gaps in between that
which I think is totally fine I'm
totally fine with the Star Wars movie
once every two years as long as we have
a really badass couple Star Wars TV
series during Star Wars Celebration
Kathleen Kennedy is like yes we're
working on Knights of the Old Republic
but she was kind of non-committal about
it it was sort of an offhanded remark
that she made in an interview now it's
been confirmed that they have been
actively developing a Knights of the Old
Republic trilogy ever since the
beginning of 2018 so even though we're
just learning about this now they've
actually been working on it for more
than a year but like I said next Star
Wars movie isn't coming till 2022
and there are now three separate Star
Wars trilogies that are in development
there's the one that Brian Johnson is
working on which is supposedly set in
present-day with completely different
characters the
aren't from the original Skywalker
movies then there's the separate trilogy
that the Game of Thrones producers are
working on we thought that that was
going to be Knights of the Old Republic
but that is not the case apparently it's
something different the Knights of the
Old Republic trilogy which is now the
third one is from a completely different
person
there's no director attached to it no
actors or anything like that it's just
being written there working on the
scripts the person's name is Leia dat
caligra TISS which I'm probably
mispronouncing but she's the person that
wrote one of James Cameron's Avatar
sequels so we haven't actually seen any
of the movies that she's made yet
because who knows when those avatar
sequels are gonna drop but if you
haven't played Knights of the Old
Republic or you're not familiar with
that franchise it said many thousands of
years before the events in present-day
so we're talking upwards of 5,000 years
ago if you've ever read the tales of the
Jedi comics the Dark Horse published a
long time ago those are actually some of
my favorite Dark Horse Star Wars comics
it's around that period the great Sith
uprising the hyperspace War all these
big conflicts that happened thousands
and thousands of years before the events
that we've seen during the modern Star
Wars films I don't expect them to just
redo the plot of the video game usually
they tend to do very original plots and
even if they are inspired by some of the
events of the video game it's the same
thing with the Marvel movies where they
kind of do the comics but things wind up
being very very different it's from a
period before the Sith rule of two so
just expect a really great-looking
version of the Sith order within that
the Sith themselves are actually a race
of people that Dark Jedi who left the
original Old Republic Empire sort of
co-opted and twisted to their own ways
until they became more of an order than
in actual people if you haven't read any
of those old Dark Horse Comics I
recommend you check them out at least a
little technically they're not candidate
expect them to pull everything from
those old comics but Dark Lords of the
Sith was awesome Golden Age of the Sis
was a really cool storyline so there's a
lot of good material to sort of
familiarize yourself with the Sith of
that period this is but a taste of the
dog what will probably happen is is that
the Lucasfilm powers-that-be will just
evaluate how viable they think each of
these separate trilogies that are being
developed are and they'll just start
with whichever one they feel like is the
strongest story so for really lucky down
the road once they figure out their
Knights of the Old Republic film
franchise
we'll also get a really badass Knights
of the Old Republic Disney Plus
streaming service show with like 8 to 10
episodes per season early guests though
we probably won't see one of these
movies if they do actually wind up
making them till 2023 2024 so it's gonna
be four or five years before we see any
of this stuff so don't hold your breath
on it but just get really excited to go
do it eventually as we start to get new
footage for the Star Wars Mandalorian TV
series all do more trailer videos for
that but remember the Disney Plus
streaming service isn't going to launch
and that show won't start till
mid-november so it's gonna be the very
end of this year but also right around
that same time Rick and Morty's season 4
is going to premiere and The Witcher
Netflix TV series is going to begin so
they'll actually be a lot of really cool
stuff happening around then I'll be
doing videos for all those series so
leave all your video requests in the
comments below and everybody just really
mind blown about this Knights of the Old
Republic stuff while you wait for
everything click here to watch the Star
Wars Episode nine trailer a billion more
times and click here for the trailer for
the Game of Thrones bonus episode and
learn all about the Game of Thrones
prequel series that'll be starting next
year thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you